et
[Musique]
les premiers nés de la nouvelle
génération de shadocks lunaires sont un
peu raté voyons un peu comment se
présentent les autres et bien rassurez
vous les autres n'étaient absolument pas
présente à lui de ridicule petit bout de
shadocks deux misérables vermicelles de
shadocks que dis-je vermicelles
lamentable revenus de shadow oui c'est
tout ce qui sortait se promettait il
avait bonne mine le ministre de la
population
lui qui avait promis à sa direction de
peu plus la lune de shadocks conquérant
de shadocks vigoureuse' surian de
shadocks populaire en somme
eh bien c'était raté cela était plutôt
disons impopulaire parce que saborder sa
s'agripper figurez-vous ces sales bêtes
là bas il avait bonne mine avec sa
petite famille en pièces détachées
pauvres bêtes éplorée avait bien essayé
de se refaire une famille présentable on
voir colorent les morceaux mais c'était
même pas standardisés enfin qu'est ce
qui s'était passé c'est que la pilule du
professeur shadow coup voyez vous
c'était bien joli cela peut répondre
plusieurs jeux à la fois mais cela ne
faisait pas pondre plusieurs shadoks à
la fois pour la raison que nous allons
essayer de vous expliquer un oeuf
normale a toujours un intérieur bien à
lui et il arrive qu'un meuf est deux ou
plusieurs intérieur à lui tout seul
c'est parra chez les shadoks non
seulement c'était pas pareil mais
c'était quasiment le contraire de sorte
que le même intérieur pour des raisons
d'un mur obscures se mettait dans
plusieurs zones et plus ont des deux à
la fois moins il y avait d'intérieur
dans chaque et moi il y avait des
shadoks c'était fatal
voilà ce qui s'était passé tout ça
c'était de la faute du chat d'oc
population et qui avait pas surveillée
c'est intérieur le chat d'oc population
faisait finement remarquer qu'il avait
été nommé ministre de la population
seulement et pas ministre de l'intérieur
piètre excuse
et pendant ce temps là les shadoks
impopulaire a imperturbablement
continuer à éclore y à un peuple et la
lune
tout n'était pas encore perdu voyez-vous
car shadow qu'on le brave professeur
shadow qu encore une fois vient d'avoir
une idée géniale et va sauver la
cinéaste
[Musique]